Hallo Wolfgang. Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen in der Garderobe und warten auf unseren
Auftritt. Es geht gleich los.
Aber zunächst wollen wir sagen, was wir lesen. Und du hast den Vorschlag gemacht,
wir können uns mal mit zwei Brüdern beschäftigen.
Nämlich sowohl Nico Semsrott, der im EU-Parlament war, und auch sein Bruder
Arne Semsrott haben jeweils ein Buch geschrieben.
Der eine über seine Zeit in Europa, der andere in dem, was man so das bürokratische
Europa nennt und der andere darüber,
was ist denn eigentlich zu tun jetzt, wo der Rechtsruck da ist,
wie könnte man da die Gesellschaft absichern dagegen, was wäre zu machen?
Ja, Arne Semsrott ist mir aufgefallen, als er einen Vortrag hielt beim KS Communication
Kongress letzten Jahres.
Einer der wenigen, der sich wirklich Gedanke über Methode und Ablauf seines
Programms gemacht hat, inklusive Adaption einer sehr beliebten Popnummer, Getanze auf der Bühne.
Also das kommt ja auch sehr entgegen. Vielleicht schauen wir da auch nochmal
kurz rein, wenn wir nächste Woche die reguläre Folge aufnehmen.
Dann waren wir gestern hier in der Oper, also wir lesen zwei Semsrott-Bücher,
alle Details lest ihr im Text, wenn ihr mitlesen wollt, ansonsten tragen wir sie euch vor.
Dann waren wir gestern hier in der Oper, das hat erstaunlich gut geklappt,
du hattest gesagt, kommt mit und wir waren zwei Hände voll Menschen,
die sich gestern La Juive angeschaut haben.
Ja, eine Grand Opera, die ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig ist,
die dich unglaublich beeindruckt hat.
Total. Ich würde sagen, ja, ein bisschen redundant an manchen Stellen,
ein bisschen sehr auf Affekte aus, die auch ein Entree Reueux produzieren könnte.
Aber das ist schon auch der Grund dafür, warum es dir so gefallen hat.
Was hast du denn jetzt gegen Konfetti?
Wir wollen jetzt gar nicht, es gab auch Konfetti, ja, wir wollen ja gar nicht
lästern. Also schön, dass einige mitgekommen sind.
Aber jetzt müssen wir noch kurz sagen, was wir heute machen. Also ich denke...
Wir klären zuerst heute, ob...
Wir kennen ja den Grundbegriff noch nicht, aber er ist ein Grundbegriff. Die Bühnenrealität.
Ob die Bühnenrealität gestern in ihrer Dramaturgie die Realität überflügelt
hat oder nicht, das kennen wir.
Und dann steigen wir ein.
Du hast Podcasts gehört. Ja, ich habe ganz viele Podcasts gehört und ich glaube,
es ist an der Zeit, und es tut mir auch ein bisschen weh, aber ich glaube,
es ist an der Zeit, Albrecht von Lucke zu canceln.
Also schlimmster Boomer Talk, kann ich versprechen. Wir überprüfen das gleich.
Ich mache nach keinem Urteil.
Gut, dann gehen wir weiter und wir sprechen über Emotionen oder was hast du dir da gesagt?
Emotionen heben wir uns wahrscheinlich auf, je nach Zeit. Wir müssen heute,
da wir ja mit Albrecht von Lucke oder über ihn urteilen, du willst ja scharf
über ihn urteilen, ich könnte mir vorstellen, es wäre ganz gut,
wenn wir danach darüber diskutieren, ob wir neue Diskussionen brauchen,
vielleicht mit neuen Grundbegriffen. Ich schlage heute einen vor.
Ich habe den ja schon mal so ein bisschen angespielt. Ich will nicht sagen geteased,
weil es war mir noch nicht klar, wie weit wir es treiben müssen.
Deswegen treiben wir es heute mal sehr weit mit einem neuen Grundbegriff für
unsere politischen Debatten.
Und dann sagst du uns, wie wir Geld verdienen. Genau, denn ich habe mich mit
passivem Einkommen beschäftigt und all den Gurus, die es da so gibt.
Und wir rechnen mal so grob durch, was man denn braucht, um von einer regelmäßigen
Rente leben zu können und nicht mehr arbeiten gehen zu müssen.
Ich glaube, da sind wir alle sehr gespannt. Außer Musik kein erfolgreiches YouTube-Genre.
Also wie viel Geld verdienen? Gut, damit haben wir alles abgehandelt,
was wir jetzt vorab abhandeln. Wir sagen noch, wie wir in den Salon kommen.
Also wer jetzt den Live-Salon, also die Show, die wir jetzt gleich abhalten,
hören will, wer auch die anderen Salons hören will, kann das Ganze einfach tun.
Nämlich muss man sich eigentlich nur mal auf die Seite begeben,
neue20er.de. Dort ist ein goldener Button.
Dann kommt man dort zu Steady und dort ist dann alles selbsterklärend.
Und dort bekommt man dann auch, wenn man ein Abo abgeschlossen hat,
eine RSS-Feed, den kann man überall einpflegen.
Das heißt, man kann dann diesen Paywall-Content überall so hören,
wie man das immer getan hat, auch mit dem üblichen Podcast.
Und dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, das über Patreon zu tun,
wenn man dort schon angemeldet ist.
Und über Spotify kommt man auch direkt über einen Button zu Steady.
Dann gibt es noch für Leute wie Stefan die Apple-Möglichkeit.
Genau, also für iPhone-Nutzer. Apple hat den Begriff ja selbst mit geprägt damals.
Der Podcast ist ja ein Broadcast auf dem iPod gewesen.
Deswegen hat Apple immer noch eine eigenständige Podcast-App,
mit der man einfach regulär leicht buchen kann.
Egal wie ihr bucht, lasst euch nicht lumpen. Ihr kriegt einen vollständigen Podcast.
Dazu gehören Kapitelmarken. Wir lesen ja Texte, die kann man einzeln anspringen.
Ihr kriegt ein schönes Cover.
Ihr kriegt ein RSS-Feed. Ihr werdet also benachrichtigt, wenn ein neuer Podcast da ist.
Ihr bekommt E-Mails von uns, wenn ein neuer Podcast da ist. Das ist wirklich
alles sehr leichtgängig.
Und ich darf das, glaube ich, sagen, gerade ist hier noch was eingetroffen.
Und zwar, bevor wir auf die Bühne gehen, mampft jetzt Stefan in atemberaubender
Geschwindigkeit noch schnell eine Pizza Hawaii.
Und dann geht's los. Ja, ich habe die vorhin vergessen zu bestellen,
aber jetzt ist sie ein bisschen später da. Aber das schaffe ich noch. Bis später.
Guten Abend. Hallo.
Wir beide sind's. Ihr kennt uns. Das ist Wolfgang. Und ihr habt's gemerkt,
im Hintergrund Attraktion in Nebel.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum. Wolfgang hat das bestellt.
Ist heute der große Frisuren-Reveal?
Nein, heute noch nicht.
Mist. Okay, dann machen wir einfach Podcast.